[Music]
it's just one more indication
of the barbarity of this organization
in the case of terrorist kidnap no
ransom should be paid brothers the blood
of david haynes
was on your hands cameron
[Music]
you mock my words if they get past us
they'll come for you
the growth of islamic state has been as
astonishingly quick
as it has been they've established
themselves as the most recognizable
terror brand in the world
al qaeda is almost considered moderate
these days
islamic state is forging links with
other terror groups
around the globe and they're willing to
collect under their umbrella
small groups too like the charlie hebdo
killers are linked to is
their strategy is to create a caliphate
in syria and iraq
and bring chaos to the region but is
that
it arguably not islamic state has a
higher goal
to provoke a global religious war
fitting all
society against itself the question
is can they achieve
the arid open spaces of northern syria
and the plentiful supplies of oil
in these enormous oil fields where
islamic state
have grown and plotted their expansion
it has been extremely well organized
from the start
the use of social media and the
production of high quality
promotional videos has allowed islamic
state to cement their brand
convey their message of jihad
but crucially it's allowed them to
effectively terrify the world
from the comfort of the cities towns and
villages they control
as a media strategy it isn't just
successful it's a genius
just warped cruel and barbaric
they've taken many hostages the majority
of foreigners
released after payments by nations
prepared to do just about anything
to say the lies of their citizens
britain the united states and japan
choose not to cooperate
the murders of their nationals have been
uncompromisingly brutal
more often than not apparently carried
out by this man
a briton known as jihadi john the
treatment
and murder of captured syrian soldiers
has been equally horrific
every event more gruesome than the last
for some of those fighting islamic state
the organization
has defied all previous thinking
it's almost like super terrorism
it's an advance in the aggression and i
remember
here with ansel islam with with a jungle
islam et cetera et cetera for example it
was very difficult to get one person to
behead somebody now they seem to be
falling over themselves to do these acts
of butchery
it definitely is a different kind of
terrorism it's a much more aggressive
more merciless brutal system
and i i say again this is this is the
front on the war on terrorism and if we
don't stop this here
they will come for the west they'll come
for england they'll come for europe
they'll come for the united states they
need to be stopped
and they need to be stopped decisively
the roots of islamic state stretch back
to the war in iraq
relentlessly targeted by american
british and iraqi security services
and eventually shunned by sunni tribes
they lost their grip
but in the chaotic uprising against the
regime of bashar al-assad
syria they found a fertile ground to
grow
in a disorganized opposition to
infiltrate and ultimately overwhelm
isis clearly enjoys the tension between
the middle east between
saudi arabia iran between syria between
turkey
that isis is very conveniently able to
exploit for its own advantage
isis is not just trying to establish
itself as
the sort of the dominant business group
in the region and in the world
but also it is a threat to the stability
of the region the tuple
just the regular political stability of
the region because it is exploiting
the weaknesses the structural um the
systematic weaknesses
of the uh russia of the administration
the surrounding countries
the only effective on-the-ground
military opposition to islamic state
has been the kurdish security forces
made up of the proud but often poorly
equipped peshmerga
and assisted by the better trained and
armed counter-terrorism group
they have protected iraq's autonomous
kurdistan
but the fighting has been harsh and has
caused many kurdish lies
the decision by the american-led
coalition to intervene militarily
through a campaign of aerial assaults
has paid dividends
islamic state have lost ground in areas
where the kurdish ground troops
and the coalition planes have
coordinated their action
the relief of kobani after months of is
attacks is the best example
but there's a growing feeling that it
simply isn't enough
although ironically that is exactly what
islamic state wants
especially the intervention of western
soldiers
isis has a product to sell the idea of
an islamic counterfeit
and it is more than willing to go to go
as far as it needs
uh with all of its propaganda to create
to create this sort of the sense of need
for an islamic for a representative of
the world's muslims
that can actually take a stand against
the west take a stand against
international forces seem to be a threat
to
devoted muslims by taking the fight
or encouraging the fight to take place
against them
in um arab countries iraq and
and and syria just underscores their
position as they see as the arbiters of
all things to do
with islam exactly and that's the great
problem
which is why sending in us having arab
states sending foreign troops is going
to be the perfect
situation compared to the uk and the us
doing so
because we need this we need a visible
muslim contingent
that is fighting isis preferably city
as is growing it's revealed its
intention to be the standard bearer of
jihad
urging foreign fighters to join the
cause this is a message
to the brothers or steve behind to
travel to the region to fight
and they have come from around the world
britain all of europe and north america
is represented here
the fear is that they will return to
continue the fight
at home
the paris attacks and the links to syria
have clear indicators
that this is more than a possibility
[Music]
some here fear that the is intention is
not just a killer mame abroad but to
fundamentally destabilize relations
between different communities bitting
muslims
christians and jews against one another
effectively
a holy war
it's everything that isis is designing
their message
to british society to western society
turn against your muslims
because the message we want to get
across as isis is that you hate them
we're telling the muslim community you
despise muslims for being muslims
and if you can show them that you
despise them for being muslims
our job is done so if they can sow
discord
amongst our countries here they've won
and we've let them won
we've let them win if we you know
the biggest asset of the west is our
freedom
is our liberties if we ourselves
as society call for an erosion of those
freedoms
uh call for people to be locked up
because they follow a certain religion
or express a certain viewpoint um view
them with suspicion
if we erode those principles ourselves
we're doing the job of the terrorists
for them we're letting them win we're
giving them victory
but islamic state isn't just content
with destabilizing countries like iraq
and syria
israel and jordan and iran for example
it is building alliances and spreading
its tentacles across the world
while islamic state is centered on what
it describes as a caliphate
straggling syria and iraq its sphere of
influence is growing
it's part of their strategy
further to the east in afghanistan and
pakistan elements of the taliban
have indicated support for is but the
terror group
is also building a presence here to
ensure taliban compliance
in africa the well-established islamic
fundamentalist groups like al-shabab
in somalia who carry out attacks across
the border in kenya
are now working as an is affiliate
to the north in the countries of nigeria
and mali terror groups
are in regular contact with and are open
supporters of is
the mass kidnapping and mass murders by
boko haram
in the north of nigeria a part of its
efforts to establish
their own caliphate
and in libya the location of the west's
previous significant intervention
is supporting militias have taken
control of tripoli
they're engaged in a battle to extend
their power base
across the country
just like the international coalition
it's it's like a multi-headed hydra but
you've got two you've got two coalitions
forming
i said this multi-headed hydra of
islamic terror
that has 10 different heads with the
chief head being that of the islamic
state
and that is how i see the future of the
islamic state rather than
all the groups merging together to form
this one big
uh you know global cal global catheter
i'm not in a scale of it i don't see it
as a homogeneous comfort
i see it as as an octopus for tentacles
of different lengths
as britain itself questions the
strategies being employed to counter
islamic state
it's clear the international community
agree on action
just what more is the question
[Music]
[Applause]
jordan finds itself the most vociferous
the most determined to seek revenge
and destroy us
but there is no question islamic state's
ambitions of creating regional chaos
promoting international social discord
and spreading jihad
is working finding a way to counter it
is the key
one of the greatest challenges in the
world today
you